so what is the deal with this crazy
break-in at Nancy Pelosi's house well I
was trying to find a legit journalist
and there's a very short list of legit
journalists Glenn Greenwald who is a
lefty a guy I've had my differences with
in the past for sure and we've gotten
into it publicly over those differences
I would consider him a legit journalist
despite our political differences he had
a super interesting thread on what
actually went on in this Pelosi break-in
here we go
it's very possible that the instantly
formed media narrative Paul Pelosi's
attacker was a Maga fanatic who broke
into murder Nancy will be proven true
but right now there are so many glaring
doubts and holes in that story that it
just takes common sense to question this
it's genuinely alarming how conditioned
so much of the U.S population is to
equate skepticism toward the
pronouncements of media corporations
pronouncements of media corporations
with mental illness if you don't
instantly accept what Wolf Blitzer and
Andrea Mitchell claimed then you're a
crazy conspiracy theorist it's so
crucial to understand the dynamic
dominating journalism few journalists
have career security imagine you're a
young journalist at a big media
Corporation you know if you ask these
questions Twitter will explode and it'll
ruin your career why wasn't there signs
of forced entry at the Pelosi home who
was the third person who opened the door
for for the police why was Pelosi
holding a hammer and attack only
happened after police arrived where is
Body cam security footage why isn't the
Press asking these questions this
happened often during russiagate I get
text DMS and emails from younger
journalists inside big media
corporations thanking me for being
skeptical they couldn't one Twitter mob
against them for questioning Dem
narrative see Dasha Burns or Bo now Bode
knows news can be career ending many
journalists see the glaring questions
and evidentiary holes in the Paul Pelosi
narrative but they also know how
important that narrative is to Democrats
right before the midterms so why stick
their heads up provoke a liberal Twitter
mob and be branded that's the climate
police investigating the Paul Pelosi
attack continue to say they do not know
the motive yet liberal thought leaders
like Hillary Clinton and Jimmy Kimmel
have decreed that not only is the motive
known to them but only insane or
malicious people would would question
them okay thank you Glenn Greenwald
because that basically explains that
there is a system of selective pressures
young journalists that would love to
find out what really happened here why
is there no security footage at the
Pelosi house the window that was broken
the glass was on the outside of the
window normally if you punch through a
window the glass would be on the inside
why was Paul Pelosi holding a hammer why
was this guy in his underwear like
there's a lot of weird stuff going on
and on top of the fact
that Paul Pelosi was just arrested for
drunk driving a month ago like the guy's
life is obviously a bit of disorder but
immediately Hillary Clinton this is
right wing crazy people right Jimmy
Kimmel jumps in it Jimmy Kimmel has no
reason to jump in on this except that
he's part of the machine ilhan Omar
immediately these are right-wing you
know blah blah blah it's like they jump
to it because in the past they knew they
could jump to it enough people would
hear what they their conclusion that
they wanted to get to and then by the
time it was disproven it wouldn't matter
anymore right that's why Brett Kavanaugh
turned out not to be a serial rapist
that's why the Jesse smith thing turned
out to be a hoax Kyle Rittenhouse wasn't
a white supremacist Russia collusion
didn't happen very fine people on both
sides in heaven we've been through this
game over and over and over and now
enough of us are realizing what the game
is and then without their algorithmic
trickery they're going to have trouble
holding on that which is why I would say
to everybody buckle up kiddo because
it's gonna get weird because they're
gonna have to be more or crazy so my
look I don't know I don't know was it a
Maga person was it a lefty was it just
some drug addict and who had a complete
crazy political assist view uh you know
set of views or had no political I have
no idea I have no idea but all these
people rushing to tell you the thing
that fits their narrative they're
telling you more about themselves than
about what actually happened